I'm sure this is not the first time that
the organization has heard of things
that he's been involved in these are the
only times that have gotten out to the
public organization has what are called
handlers for their star players and they
go around one of our boys was Dirk's
handle and it's his job to make sure
Dirk don't get nobody pregnant to make
sure Dirk is not the Highland Hitler in
the goddamn bar in Texas somewhere you
know what I mean like that's literally
their job that's a joke
basically what happens is there's a guy
who's with John that's from the team and
he's telling the team yo he's out here
he's wildling he's doing these kind of
things like he's a wild dude it's like
can you control him probably not he has
his friends who are all clout
Goblin gold digging idiots because
you're about to up the gold mine
yep yep like don't put your boy on live
ever yeah